let's talk a little bit about credit in
particular how much you pay for credit
so just as a reminder credit is
essentially the ability or when you
actually borrow from someone else it
could take the form of a mortgage where
you say you're borrowing money to buy a
house or it could take the form of a
credit card where when you purchase
things with that credit card you are
borrowing money from the bank issuer in
order to purchase whatever you want now
credit can be useful it could be
convenient in the case of a credit card
where you don't have to carry cash
around some places only accept credit or
credit card and it can help you and
sometimes make good Investments for
example if you borrow money in order to
make an investment that's going to
return more money than you put in but
you have to be careful there's always
some risk involved that actually could
be a good financial decision
now we also have to be very very very
careful especially if you're using
credit to buy something that isn't an
investment that's really just all about
consumption hey there's a new outfit I
want I'm going to use credit for it
maybe you're using it for the
convenience and you're going to pay off
the balance at the end of the month but
if you're using it because you actually
don't have the money that is a bad sign
that is a sign that you are spending
more money than you are bringing in and
you're using credit to kind of not
notice that and the reason why that's a
big deal is one you're spending
unsustainably but the other issue is
there's usually a a pretty significant
cost especially two credit cards all
credit someone's going to charge you
interest for the amount that you borrow
and there's usually going to be some
fees on top of that and one way to think
about the cost of credit you'll see
something called APR these are annual
percentage rate and what they do in the
same in the case of a credit card they
look at your average doubt daily balance
and they're going to charge a certain
amount of interest plus fees on that
average daily balance now if you were to
just keep that balance all all year you
would actually have to compound that
average daily balance by 365 days but to
simplify the calculation APR just takes
how much interest you would pay times
365. so it actually understates a little
bit it's actually the interest plus the
fees you would pay as a percentage times
365 which actually understates a little
bit what you would pay if you actually
had to compound but it's a good
standardized measure of roughly what
you're going to pay for a loan it's not
uncommon for a credit card APR to be in
the High Teens or even in the 20s in
some cases I've even seen them in the 30
range that is a lot of that's a lot of
expense to pay a to borrow money
especially if you're not using it for
Investments
mortgages will also have aprs although
they will be significantly lower mainly
because of people lending to you view
that as a safer bet from their point of
view and even when you're using it with
a credit for what you think are
investments you have to be very
conscientious of risk because credit is
really a way of getting leverage and we
can talk more about that in other videos
it can magnify how much you you make if
say the asset increases in value but it
can also magnify how much you lose if
the asset decreases in value we'll talk
about that at other times but generally
speaking be very careful about credit
especially if you're using it to buy if
you're using it to consume versus invest
and look at that APR it's a standardized
way of really getting a sense of how
costly that loan is